the times we live in are truly and
without doubt fascinating
in the past several hundred years people
have learned to travel comparatively
fast on land and water and more recently
have even managed to fly to some space
objects near nearest
however a proper space tour remains a
dream rather than becomes a real
possibility right now
and so i invite you to join me on a
virtual tour
in the course of our little trip we will
fly by the most amazing objects in the
nearest parts of our universe at the
speed of light
we will set off at the orbit of ceres
then we'll go as far as orcas and pass
some really bizarre stars on our way
further and back
fasten your seat belts
let's go
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
an object with these properties is ceres
the second smallest dwarf planet within
the solar system after hygeia until
recent past it used to be considered the
smallest dwarf planet in our system
series was discovered back in 1801 by
the italian astronomer giuseppe piazzi
and used to be considered a fully
fledged planet of our system for a long
time however in 2006 this celestial body
was eventually classified as a dwarf
planet with a diameter measuring
approximately 950 kilometers ceres is
the largest and the most massive body in
the asteroid belt
it also beats many satellites of giant
planets in terms of size the diameter of
enceladus for instance is twice as small
measuring 504 kilometers
series's mass accounts for almost 32
percent of the total mass of the
asteroid belt it was possible to
determine this following the analysis of
the object's influence on other smaller
objects and the belt
according to the average value of three
most accurate estimates made by 2008
series as mass is considered to be this
9.4 multiplied by 10 to the power of 20
or 1.3 percent of the mass of the moon
or else almost six thousand times as
little as the mass of our planet
even though ceres is three and a half
times smaller than the moon the contrast
of their masses is stark but the reason
lies in the fact that they differ in
their chemical composition as our moon
is made up mainly of hard rocks
ceres has a spherical shape which is
untypical of most other small celestial
bodies
it assumed this shape due to the
influence of its own gravitation this is
the major difference between series and
large asteroids like palace or juno
which are not spherical in shape
the object's area is 2849.000
square kilometers
just to compare it is slightly bigger
than argentina
unlike with other asteroids a special
feature is peculiar to series after it
assumed a spherical shape there started
gravitational differentiation of rocks
and the object's interior briefly
explained it's a process when heavier
rocks shift to the core with lighter
ones forming an outer layer thus series
came to possess a rocky core and a cryo
mantle made up of water ice
the mantle is a hundred kilometers thick
and accounts for 23 to 28 percent of the
object's mass as well as for half its
volume in addition it contains about 200
million cubic kilometers of water in the
form of ice which is more than there is
fresh water on earth
speaking about the formation process of
this dwarf planet it is assumed that
ceres's core could have been heated up
as a result of radioactive decay in the
first stage of the asteroid's life
at the same time some part of the icy
mantle may have been in the liquid state
at the time
it looks like the surface is still for
the most part covered with ice or some
kind of icy surface regolith the
question of cryovolcanism on series
still remains open too
following analysis of data collected by
the dawn probe the largest mountain on
series for instance called ahuna mons is
a nicey cryo volcano
this is evidence that the dwarf planet
has been geologically active for at
least the last billion years for all we
know ceres may well be active right now
seen from the earth ceres is rather dim
and its visible disc is extremely small
that is why finer details were
distinguished on it only at the end of
last century with the help of the hubble
space telescope
there is a number of light and dark
spots to be seen on the asteroid's
surface which appear to be craters
the brightest one of these has been
dubbed piazzi
probably this spot is a crater spilling
some of the icy mantle or perhaps
showing a cryovolcano
further observation of the object in the
infrared range revealed the average
surface temperature which is 167 degrees
kelvin or 106 degrees celsius below zero
thanks to the observations of the dwarf
planet in the radio spectrum it was
ascertained that ceres's surface is
quite smooth come to think of it it is
hardly surprising as the icy mantle
should be quite elastic
telescopic investigation has remained
the only observation method employed to
study series until 2015. thus water
vapor clouds around the object were
spotted in january 2014 thanks to the
herschel infrared space telescope
this is how ceres came to be the fourth
celestial body in the solar system with
registered water activity
the other three are enceladus europa and
of course our earth
the dawn interplanetary space probe
launched in 2007 heralded the most
momentous stage in studying the dwarf
planet
having drifted in vesta's orbit for a
while dawn proceeded to make the
acquaintance of ceres and on the 13th of
january 2015 it captured the first
detailed images of the asteroid's
surface on the 8th of february the probe
was just some 118 000 kilometers away
from the object heading towards it at a
speed of 360 kilometers per hour
on the 18th and 25th of february 2015
nasa published detailed pictures of the
dwarf planet where two bright white
spots are clearly seen
the spots were later identified as
supposedly the chemical element sodium
carbonate also known as soda
dawn went on to enter the asteroids
orbit on march the 6th where it was to
stay for the next 16 months to carry on
observation it is in this period that it
was able to take images of the puzzling
white spots and to this day these photos
are the best we have of them
the probe's mission was over on june the
30th 2016.
the data beamed back to the earth helped
estimate the dwarf planet's mass and
size and also provide hard evidence of
there being water ice on the planet's
surface
and it is likely to be found inside the
craters
634 such craters have been spotted in
the northern polar area of ceres 10 of
which contain deposits of bright
material
ice formation has been spectroscopically
identified in one of them
spectra in 2015 revealed no water but
revealed presence of hydroxyl rich
materials and a somewhat weaker streak
of ammonium it is likely to be
ammonia-rich clay where water is
chemically bound and comes forth as
hydroxyl
thanks to the data revealed by the dawn
probe it was possible to make certain
conclusions about the craters since the
number of large craters is smaller than
expected it is logical to assume that
the surface undergoes gradual changes as
a result of all studies that have been
carried out it is suggested that water
vapor is likely to account for 20 to 30
percent of series
apart from that various hydrous minerals
and substances may be found in the
surface composition carbonates and clays
rich in iron
ceres hasn't been discovered to have any
moons
based on observations using the hubble
telescope it is safe to say that even if
there are any moons they cannot be over
20 kilometers in diameter
but be it as it may the history of
studying this space object isn't over
yet
in the next decade the chinese national
space administration or cnsa is planning
to take soil samples from the dwarf
planet's surface
ceres is often associated with another
large object in the asteroid belt
the celestial body in question is called
vesta and is considered to be the
largest known asteroid in terms of size
and mass
in fact vesta is clearly seen even with
a naked eye from our planet's surface
its parameters are 578 by 560 by 458
kilometers
were it not so asymmetrical it would
also be classified as a dwarf planet as
it would then qualify to be called one
according to the updated classification
of the solar system objects
the combined mass of western palace
another large asteroid is half that of
ceres
at the same time vesta is 25 percent
heavier than palace
the surface temperature investor
fluctuates between 106 and 3 degrees
celsius below zero
and here is a picture of both vesta and
series taken by the curiosity mars rover
in 2014
several decades ago an object like ceres
would pose quite a riddle for scientists
today however we're able to speak with
relative certainty about its makeup
chemical composition and history of
formation
the kuiper belt is an area in the solar
system stretching from neptune's orbit
to a 55 astronomical units away from the
sun
in many ways it resembles the asteroid
belt but in contrast the kuiper belt is
20 times as wide and approximately 100
times as massive
for the most part it is made up of small
bodies basically debris of material left
after the formation of the solar system
unlike the asteroid belt objects
celestial bodies and the kuiper belt
consist for the most part of volatile
elements like methane and water
there are at least four officially
confirmed dwarf planets in this area and
it is here the talcus was discovered
the object was spotted on the 17th of
february 2004 by american astronomers
michael brown
chad trujillo and david rabinowitz
the scientists were able to distinguish
it in some archive images taken back on
the 8th of november 1951.
now let's take a closer look at it
orcas is a large trans-neptunian object
of the plutino category
apart from orcas other celestial objects
of this category include pluto ixion and
who you are
objects like that are locked in a 2-3
resonance with neptune which means that
when a plutino orbits the sun twice
neptune orbits it three times in the
same period
the furthest point from the sun
regularly reached by orcas is 48
astronomical units and the closest it
ever gets to the sun is 30 astronomical
units
orcas diameter supposedly measures 946
kilometers which is approximately 40
percent that of pluto
its surface temperature is 229 degrees
celsius below zero
it is largely thanks to orcas moon
discovered in february 2007 that
scientists are able to have clearer
ideas about orcis's properties
the discovery of the moon was michael
brown's achievement too and the object
was dubbed vanth
it takes vanth 9 and a half days to
complete one full orbit around orcas
the distance between them is nine
thousand kilometers
it is posited that august and valve are
in synchronous rotation
that is they face each other at all
times with the same sides pluto and its
satellite karen are locked in the same
manner vance diameter is estimated at
approximately 280 kilometers and the
object's orbit around orcas is
practically circular however these
parameters for both vanth and daukis are
still admittedly not very accurate at
this point
wants mass may account for three to
seven and a half percent of the total
mass of both objects
as we've mentioned before vanth is just
9 000 kilometers away from orcas which
is too close for its surface composition
to be spectroscopically analyzed it is
suggested however that vanth may have
been captured from the kuiper belt at
some point
the total mass of vanthan darkest is 3.8
percent that of aries one of the most
massive dwarf planets known today
but the way the mass is distributed
between orcas and its satellite depends
on the ratio of their sizes
investigations of orchesis spectrum
found that the signal absorption by
water ice there is the strongest among
hyperbelt objects not related to the
haumea family
large uranium satellites have a similar
spectrum
among other trans-neptunian objects it
is karen pluto's satellite that
resembles orcas the most they have
similar density and water ice was
detected on the surfaces of both
orchis spectrum differs a lot from that
of other transneptunian objects
red is to be found in ixion spectrum for
example but infrared there is rather
faint
orcas's visible spectrum is of a neutral
faint hue
further infrared observations of orcus
confirmed that there is water ice and
carbonaceous compounds in its
composition
the parameters of orcis's orbit make one
think of those of pluto in the past 14
000 years the distance between orcis and
neptune has never been shorter than 18
astronomical units
and even though orcis's orbit almost
brushes that of neptune the strong tilt
does not allow the objects get closer
the rotation period of orcas still
remains to be found out
photometric studies give rather
scattered results from 7 to 21 hours
now let's take a look at its surface
which is comparatively bright
the ice discovered on it is for the most
part in crystals which may be indicative
of cryovolcanic activity
other compounds like methane or ammonium
may also be found in orcus
interestingly to date ammonium hasn't
been discovered on any trans-neptunian
object a rice moon save miranda
in addition models of internal heating
by thermonuclear fusion suggests the
talcus is able to sustain a subsurface
ocean of liquid water
since there are water ice crystals and
possibly ammonium ice to be found it may
be indicative of renewal mechanisms that
may have been active on orcis's surface
in the past
cryovolcanism may well have been one of
these mechanisms
a single eruption may have taken place
on orcas at some point turning amorphous
water into ice crystals
as for the origins of this celestial
body scientists are still at odds trying
to find an answer to this question
according to amy barr and meg schwambe
orcus may have been formed when some
celestial objects collided at a low
speed
there are also doubts as to what
category orcus falls into
today orcas is a possible dwarf planet
but this is just a suggestion that may
potentially be disputed rather than a
unanimous opinion
apart from orcas there are at least 40
other similar dwarf planet candidates
known to science today and according to
preliminary estimates the number of
possible dwarf planets in the entire
solar system which haven't been
discovered yet may well exceed two
thousand
the number of officially acknowledged
dwarf planets today is six
these are ceres hygeia and
transneptunian objects pluto aerys
makimaki and haumea
and if you would like me to tell you
more about these please let me know in
the comments below
to qualify as a dwarf planet and to get
on the list of the acknowledged ones
august has to satisfy certain parameters
namely astronomers have to make sure
that firstly august orbits the sun
secondly that its mass is sufficient to
maintain a spherical shape
thirdly that it is not any planet's
satellite and last but not least that it
is not able to get rid of debris it may
come across in its path
at this point august comes forth on the
list of likely dwarf planets
beaten only by the following celestial
objects
gong gong kwawa and 2002 ms4
let's look at the minoda gong gong is
one of the largest trans-neptunian
objects
and it was discovered on the 17th of
june 2007 by michael brown's team
its diameter supposedly measures
1535 kilometers
its mass is 75 percent bigger than that
of ceres it is only slightly bigger than
that of kwawa
it has a moon called shang liu in its
orbit which is 15 000 kilometers away
from it and whose diameter is 300
kilometers
kwawa is a trans-neptunian object too
which may rightfully be called one of
the largest in the kuiper belt
just like gong gong it was also
discovered by michael brown's team and
it happened the same year that 2002 ms4
was added on the astronomical map
quahog's diameter is estimated at
approximately 1 100 kilometers
it has a moon in its orbit with a
diameter of 74 kilometers named wayward
2002 ms4 is the third likely dwarf
planet candidate and according to some
estimates it boasts a diameter of about
930 kilometers
all these celestial bodies including
orcas may be considered rather large for
ones in the kuiper belt their parameters
lead scientists to think them very
likely to be dwarf planets
which may mean that one of them will
probably be officially granted this
status very soon
it is also highly likely that it is
august that will make this new dwarf
planet in the solar system but while it
isn't the case yet this celestial object
remains to be figured out and its
further exploration may reveal new
exciting evidence that is still lying in
store for us
interstellar travel has always been one
of mankind's cherished dreams
over half a century has elapsed since
the launch of the earth's first
artificial satellite
and since then terrestrial spacecraft
have covered truly record distances on
escape trajectories from the earth
the voyages were among the pioneer
spacecraft to set out in space with
their top traveling speed reaching 62
140 kilometers per hour
juno is the second super fast space
probe worth mentioning here which
approached jupiter at 250 000 kilometers
per hour as for the recently launched
parker solar probe it is able to propel
itself at up to 700 000 kilometers per
hour as a rule the speed of such
spacecraft is generally attained with
the use of gravity boost maneuvers that
is when a spacecraft enters into an
object's orbit which helps increase its
speed
this trick works well within our system
but be it as it may in order to travel
as far as stars scientists will have to
think of other strategies as there may
not be enough celestial objects on the
spaceship's way through interstellar
space which would help to perform
gravity boost maneuvers it is quite
possible that in the future terrestrial
spacecraft will be able to reach the
ultimate speed for traveling around the
universe
however to date only light is able to
travel that fast
its speed is traditionally considered
the limit and is a constant at 299
458 meters per second
any particle with a mass will never
reach the speed and any particle without
a mass will always travel at this exact
speed in the vacuum
the concept of an engine which would be
able to exceed the speed of light has
long been considered preposterous in
scientific circles
while considering flying to neighbouring
stellar systems was completely out of
the question
but as time goes by and with sufficient
global knowledge the most audacious
ideas may prove realistic thanks to
being widely promoted by science fiction
films the warp drive became the first
project of this scale
the history of its development goes back
to 1994
when mexican scientist miguel kubier
assumed that the concept of traveling at
superluminal speeds could be considered
as einstein's equation solved in theory
the equation defines the relation
between space time and energy in our
universe
in plain language in his theory the
mexican scientist puts forward the idea
of traveling in the manor when a
spacecraft is cocooned in a bubble of
space
the warp drive inside it makes the space
in front of the bubble contract and the
space behind the bubble to expand with a
spacecraft in between remaining
motionless
thus the bubble is able to travel
together with the spaceship at an
unlimited speed which beats even the
speed of light
this travel could be compared with
moving on a surfboard with a surfer
remaining motionless and the board
propelled forward by waves
at the end of last century this idea
could seem pseudo-scientific
but due to a loophole in physical laws
this may be manageable
it isn't the object that is moving but
the space around it and space is capable
of traveling at greater speeds than
light
by and by still more space-time
properties were discovered by science
and many scientists were attracted by
the concept of the warp drive
in 2007 thanks to the gravity probe b
project the ability of space to get
warped in the vicinity of massive
objects was proved once and for all
in 2015 thanks to the ligo observatory
the first gravity waves were detected in
the form of space-time perturbations
which may be described as ripples in
space
as recently as in august 2008 dozens of
science groups were offered by the
ministry of defense of the united states
to look into prospects of exploring new
aerospace technologies
a report on a warp drive was the most
striking of the presented papers
its authors argued that the creation of
the warp drive would be closely linked
with studying dark energy
the force that makes the universe expand
with an accelerating velocity
at the time the report prompted a lot of
debate among dark matter and energy
specialists however ten years later the
idea of a warp jump was brought up again
in 2019 american engineer joseph agnew
revealed the results of his work where
he was able to break down the theory of
the warp jump propulsion force into
simple comprehensible bits
according to the scientists the warp
deformation can be unleashed by means of
space-time contraction and expansion
which would be aimed in a specified
direction at a specified time
today the emergence of such technologies
seems unthinkable but even now
scientists are aware of the fact that
high density energy is able to cause a
necessary warp in time space
in the future science will most likely
have to advance technologies generating
such energy forms to the ultimate level
which means that only in decades will
these experiments yield results
apart from the futuristic warp drives
however there is a great number of
projects which are not less exciting and
more down to earth as it were
the iron thruster is one of them with
several organizations currently working
on it
the general principle of its work lies
in ionizing gas and accelerating it with
electrostatic field
since ions have a mass they can be
accelerated which will produce the
thrust
the ion thruster contains some gas which
is ionized with a gas charge where gas
atoms with a neutral charge are split
into negative electrons and positive
ions
after that ions are accelerated by an
electric field in a sophisticated system
of grids
this same system blocks the movement of
electrons
on leaving the nozzle positive particles
are neutralized by negative electrons so
that the ions do not go back to the
drive and do not impede its thrust
in theory this method allows
accelerating ions up to 210 kilometers
per second
which is considerably higher than the
speed of particles and chemical rocket
jets used in all contemporary space and
military rockets their speed reaches
just four kilometers per second at the
moment existing engines of this kind
lack in power and are applicable only
for adjusting the orbit's trajectory
however if future scientists are able to
create a more powerful version of the
iron thruster it will allow spaceships
to reach the surface of mars in just 39
days which is approximately seven times
as fast as the current optimal travel
time it takes to get to the red planet
another possible option that may present
itself for travelling to the neighboring
celestial objects will probably involve
nuclear rocket engines the principle of
their work will lie in a source heating
up as a result of the decay of
radioactive material
this approach was tested at the
beginning of the space age but so far it
has been inapplicable due to two factors
firstly the use of these technologies
would lead to harmful emissions of large
amounts of radioactive waste into space
secondly the nuclear engine requires
intensive cooling which would be
difficult to achieve in space
only low power nuclear engines are known
to science today with several countries
already working on the development of
more powerful and safer versions for
example in 2017
nasa and bwxt nuclear energy signed a
contract on the development of a
technology of this kind which will
enable terrestrial spacecraft to reach
planets like saturn in a few months time
perhaps even the next generation of
people will live to see the day when
they can freely travel around our system
and cover enormous distances between
planets within a matter of a few months
however we should remember that all the
projects mentioned currently exist only
in theory and their realization has
equal chances of success or failure
man will always try to break away from
the limits imposed by the surroundings
sooner or later one of these attempts is
going to be successful
it is quite possible for a breakthrough
to take place even this century
meanwhile what remains for us to do is
to marvel at discoveries in today's
physics and to hope that the history of
mankind will not end on this planet
the location of this exoplanet would be
known to many or at this point in the
video would be guessed by many
it is the triple stellar system alpha
centauri
the system is made up of three
components
interestingly two of them are seen as a
single object which is also one of the
brightest dots in our sky
these two are alpha centauri a and alpha
centauri b
as for the third component alpha
centauri c it is a very dim red dwarf
and it was this third humble one that
caught astronomers eye
the first two components are located
quite close together while the third one
is barely visible that is the reason why
the system is often referred to as a
single star
alpha centauri never quite leaves the
horizon and can be easily seen with a
naked eye in such places around the
world as buenos aires in argentina or
sydney and melbourne in australia
the first two components of the system
are very similar to our sun in their
properties
alpha centauri a for example was the
first star whose atmosphere was directly
observed
as a result a thin cold layer was
discovered and this is one of the
similarities with the host star of our
earth
the age of the alpha centauri system is
estimated at six billion years which is
essentially one and a half billion years
more than the age of our sun the a and b
components follow an elliptical orbit
around the common mass center and their
orbital period is 79.91
years
as for the third component of the system
generally referred to as proxima
centauri it is located about .21 light
years away from either of the two stars
and it takes it about half a million
years to complete a full orbit around
them
proxima centauri is 4.24 light years
away from the earth or 270 000 times
further from us than the sun is
following some calculations it was
concluded that its actual diameter is
about seven times smaller than that of
our sun and is just one and a half times
bigger than that of jupiter
like many other red dwarves this is a
flare star and its luminosity
dramatically increases several times in
the course of its flaring up
this may well be indicative of the
object's impressive age
proxima centauri was spotted back in
1915 by the astronomer robert inns who
noticed a star moving in a way similar
to the other two objects in the system
that is how we came up with a suggestion
of its name proxima centauri which
literally translates as the closest
in 1998 the spectrometer on the hubble
space telescope registered a planet half
an astronomical unit away from proxima
centauri but investigations that
followed failed to confirm the discovery
only on the 24th of august 2016 was the
european southern observatory able to
confirm that there was an earth-like
planet in the habitable zone of the star
it was then given the name proxima
centauri b
first real evidence of this planet's
existence was provided by a group of
scientists headed by mikutumi an
astronomer from finland in 2013
when they were going through archived
data from two spectrometers namely harps
and the ultraviolet and visual a shell
spectrograph mounted on the vlt the very
large telescope
in order to confirm the possibility of
discovering the exoplanet in january
2016 a campaign was launched by the
european southern observatory and was
given the name the pale red dot several
months later on the 24th of august 2016
the existence of proxima centauri b was
officially confirmed by a team of
scientists headed by the spanish
astronomer german glades scude and
announced by the european southern
observatory
the planet was detected by the radial
velocity method also known as doppler
spectroscopy
it is an indirect method of planet
detection where periodic doppler shifts
in the spectral lines allow one to say
whether there is a planet orbiting a
star or not proxima centauri b proved to
be the closest exoplanet nearest to us
it is located 7.3 million kilometers
away from proxima centauri and its
orbital period around its host star is
completed within 11.2 earth days
but even though it is comparatively
close to its star the latter is quite
dim and the planet receives just enough
heat for the water on its surface to
remain in the liquid state rather than
turn into perennial ice
the minimal mass of proxima b is 1.27
that of our earth
following the assumption that the
planet's rock composition and density
are identical to those of the earth its
radius must measure 1.1 that of our
planet
the light received by proxima b from its
parent star is 65 of that received by
our earth from the sun
the steady-state surface temperature is
234 degrees kelvin or 39 degrees celsius
below zero
[Music]
a couple of years ago this twin of our
earth's would make for a sensational
scientific discovery and would be
assumed to almost certainly be populated
by living organisms but had it been the
case and had life forms been discovered
on that planet the video on our channel
would definitely bear a different title
as it is at this point scientists cannot
say for sure whether the planet is
actually habitable
according to today's estimates since
proxima centauri b has supposedly no
magnetic field it receives 60 times more
high energy radiation and 400 times more
x-ray radiation than our earth
in theory these figures admit of a
biosphere where biological fluorescence
is a protection mechanism used to shield
against ultraviolet radiation flares
this phenomenon is known to be
widespread among some species of coral
polyps or anthozoa and is also to be
observed on exoplanets orbiting active
stars
however just a year after the planet's
discovery a disconcerting event in the
history of the planet destroyed all
hopes so cherished by scientists in
march 2017 a powerful flare on proxima
centauri was registered by astronomers
using the atacama large millimeter array
radio telescope the host's star's
brightness intensified a thousand times
and stayed that way for 10 seconds
proxima centauri b would have
experienced an overwhelming amount of
radiation from this flare and if there
had been any biosphere on that planet
this event would have wiped it out
completely
scientists believe that if flares like
that occur regularly they would have
completely stripped the exoplanet of its
atmosphere thus rendering the surface
absolutely uninhabitable
it's worth mentioning here that
radiation endurance of microorganisms
like denococcus radiodurans allows us to
foster hopes that hypothetically life
may yet develop on that planet following
a course of evolution of its own
this isn't the end of the proxima
centauri systems story yet in 2019
astronomers from the observatory of
turin announced the discovery of another
exoplanet candidate in the star's
vicinity
the object was dubbed proxima centauri
sea and may hypothetically boast a mass
at least six times that of our earth
alpha centauri is currently seen as one
of the first destinations for
interstellar flights in the future even
in 2016 preparations for the flight of a
nano satellite driven by laser sails to
alpha centauri were announced to be in
progress
the flight time to the closest star was
estimated at 15 years
the name of the project is breakthrough
starshot and apart from reaching its
planned destination it has one more
mission
scientists plan first and foremost to
prove the feasibility of the concept
flights like that are based on
of course now it is too early to say
anything
many would argue that there cannot be
life on other planets as too many space
factors need to neatly combine to
provide favorable conditions
most scientists on the other hand refuse
to passively resign to this and so the
search for exoplanets doesn't cease
sooner or later telescopes will get
advanced to such a point that it will
take us just a casual peek through one
to be able to tell if there are any
developing life forms on a given planet
and all mysteries of exoplanets will be
effectively dispersed
and if we really discover nothing with
these extra powerful telescopes the only
thing for us to say with any certainty
will be how lucky we are to be
inhabitants of our earth
systems with this number of stars are
rather rare
what we see while observing the stars
are generally binary systems that is
systems consisting of two objects
as for multiple systems that is those
made up of three or more stars they are
by far rarer
there are two varieties of multiple
systems
namely optical and physical
objects and optical systems are located
far from each other but seen from the
earth they appear to be just one star
objects and physical systems meanwhile
are actually close together and are
bound by gravity
most physical multiple systems consist
of just three objects
it is triple systems that account for
about 70 percent of all systems of this
kind known to us today
the caster system however is noticeably
different from the majority
each of the three main stars in this
system is a binary star
thus the total number of stars in caster
is six
it is also highly unlikely that there is
stars in areas unobservable to us in
caster's vicinity which are
gravitationally bound to this sextuple
system
the more components a multiple system
contains the fewer such systems there
are in space
this means that systems consisting of
three and more stars must be extremely
rare in the universe
it goes without saying that we're far
from possessing all data about multiple
systems statistics that is why we can't
but admit that in theory there may be
systems with still more components
somewhere in deep space
getting back to the caster system this
is the second brightest object in the
constellation gemini
it is beaten only by pollux an orange
hued giant star
in terms of luminosity in our sky caster
holds the 23rd place
the system is 50.88 light years away
from our earth and its age is estimated
at approximately 200 million years
it was discovered back in the 17th
century and even then it was classified
as a binary system
and later astronomers managed to spot
several other objects physically bound
to it
the first and the main component of the
system was dubbed caster a a
this is a main sequence star of spectral
type a15
it is about twice as heavy as our sun
and its radius is also two sun's radii
the surface temperature on caster
reaches approximately 9140
kelvin
at the same time the object's luminosity
is 30 times that of our sun
the second component's designation is
caster ba it is of spectral type a25m
and its mass is 1.7 times that of the
sun with its radius measuring 1.6 that
of the sun
caster ba orbits its companion
starcaster aa it takes the two objects
about 350 years to complete a full orbit
around each other
it was later found that the eclipsing
variable star yy geminorum is also
physically bound to caster
it is a star of spectral type m .55 e
its mass is 0.62 that of the sun and its
radius is 0.76 that of the sun that made
it the third component in the system
so it was rightfully designated caster
ca
this star follows an elongated
elliptical orbit around the system's
bary center
scientists estimate its orbital period
at 14 000 years
as for its location it is approximately
1 100 astronomical units away from its
two companions
each of these stars is binary which
means that each of them has a secondary
companion of its own
let's look at them
caster av is strongly bound to caster a
and its mass is about half that of the
sun
caster bb is a star's spectrotype m25
and its mass is also about half that of
the sun
caster cb is a starved spectrotype
m.55e and is slightly heavier at point
five seven sun's mass and with a radius
of 0.68 that of the sun
caster cb is almost identical with
caster ca in its properties as the
surface temperature of both is
approximately
3820 degrees kelvin and their luminosity
is less than 10 percent that of the sun
all the six stars orbit around a common
center of mass or barry center and their
overall luminosity is 52.4 times that of
the sun
caster a a and caster ba are white stars
interestingly the former is 30 times and
the latter 14 times brighter than the
sun
by contrast casters ca and caster cb are
typical red dwarfs
according to scientists caster a a and
caster ba are supposed to remain in the
main sequence stage for at least several
hundred million years
the red dwarves meanwhile like caster ca
and cb have a much longer expected
lifespan
this is due to the slow process of
thermonuclear fusion of hydrogen and so
they may last from several billion to
tens of trillions of years
scientists are currently busy looking
for exoplanets in the caster system
however so far they have not been able
to discover as much as a hint of
exoplanets in the system
perhaps the system is too young to have
produced any or else more advanced
methods of detection are called for
it is too early to speak about other
physical properties of these stars it is
quite difficult to study them because
they are optical doubles and seen from
the earth only seem to be close whereas
it is an illusion
that is why special spectrometers are
necessary to take care of accurate
measurements
we can see all the six stars from our
earth as a single object and it is
located in the northern hemisphere in
the constellation gemini
the best time to observe them is in
winter and spring
it is easy to locate casting in the sky
as it is bright enough and can be found
near a well-known asterism called the
winter circle or the winter hexagon this
asterism is made up of pollux capella
aldebaran
rigel sirius and procyon
it is best seen in the night sky in
northern latitudes in the wintertime
february is the best month to observe
caster and pollux
it's worth mentioning that caster is a
star system that leads a group of at
least 16 celestial bodies
the point is that these stars move
together and have similar velocities and
their rage is similar
that is why they have been dubbed by
scientists as the caster moving group or
cast to stream it includes such
well-known astronomical objects as
fomalhaut vega alderamin alpha libri and
others
the question of caster's stellar
evolution still remains open
as i've mentioned before most telescopes
are incapable of revealing finer details
of these stars as they're too close
together as seen from the earth
according to some scientists systems of
this kind are formed as a result of a
big star split into two components by
centrifugal force
others claim that they originate when
one star gravitationally captures the
other
there is also a theory of compound
nucleus formation that suggests a
molecular clouds fragmentation with
stars forming as a result
then there is a theory involving
proto-stellar discs that suggests sudden
cooling of gas in a massive protostellar
disc so several stellar companions may
simultaneously originate in one in the
same plane following the disk's
fragmentation
be it as it may most facts indicate that
multiple systems originate in one place
rather than from scattered sources
in the case of the caster system its
components are believed to have been
formed out of one molecular cloud in the
same period
where a hypothetical exoplanet to find
itself in the caster system its
inhabitants would have enjoyed rather
bizarre natural phenomena
for example the planet would receive
light from several stars at the same
time so there would be several sunrises
and sunsets a day at least it seems
bizarre and exotic to us as we live in
the light of only one star
if the sun had a companion with similar
parameters the earth would get twice as
much heat and light with all that it
implies
and the sky above us would have a
totally different aspect
and it is hard to imagine what a sky
with several stars like our sun would
look like
this mind-boggling sight is straight
from a world of fantasy
but that's what we would see if we were
to find ourselves in the caster system
this binary system has been on the
astronomical map for several decades and
all the while has been thought of as
just one super bright star
my camelo pardolis or my cam for short
is 13 000 light years away from the
earth it used to be classified as a
variable star
the object aroused interest only as late
as in 2014
when a group of spanish scientists was
able to define mycam as a binary star
system
the discovery was made thanks to a 2.2
meter telescope in the kala alto
observatory
both stars boast a comparatively big
mass and are drawn quite close together
with their router atmospheres almost
touching
one of them is 38 masses of our sun
and the mass of its companion is 32
masses of our sun
the radius of each measures 700 those of
our planet
just to compare it's six times the
radius of our sun
as for the age of these objects they're
comparatively young and cannot be over
two million years old
my cam may well be called one of the
most massive binary star systems known
to science
both objects of the system are hot blue
o type stars
their rotation speed may reach up to 1
million kilometers per hour
with the surface temperature of each of
them as high as 40 000 kelvins the
orbital period around their common
center is about 28 hours which means
that both giants complete a full orbit
around each other in a bit over a day
just to compare our sun completes one
full rotation in 26 days
my cam is also quite bright which makes
it visible even through a common
telescope
the stars orbit is a rather narrow one
which is why they're alternately
eclipsed practically every day
this explains constant changes in their
luminosity
before this fact became known scientists
used to be confused about the properties
of this stellar system
the existence of my cam doesn't seem to
be that incredible considering the fact
that most celestial bodies in the milky
way were formed in big stellar systems
whose objects were also variable and
eclipsing stars
this means that these objects overall
luminosity may vary from time to time
m y cam can be called one of the best
known stellar systems of the kind in
fact it seems to have been originally
formed like this and has always looked
the way we can observe it today
since the components are in such close
proximity sooner or later they are bound
to collide and then merge into one
enormous star whose mass may well reach
as much as 60 sun masses
thanks to theoretical modelling it is
assumed that when stars merge it is a
quick procedure accompanied by a big
bang with incredible amounts of energy
released as a result
if this happens with my cam astronomers
will be able to observe this
demonstration confirming the theory that
supermassive stars are formed when two
less massive objects merge
to date science has not yet witnessed a
merging process of this kind
the possibility of our sons taking part
in a similar process is quite negligible
according to today's estimates a
collision of the main star of our system
with another star may take place once
every 10 to the power of 28 years
but even with such a miniscule chance of
this collision our earth would be
seriously affected where it could take
place somewhere close by space standards
if it were to happen within a hundred
light years from us
our blue planet would be completely
devastated
however at this point there isn't a
single star cluster within that range
so far we have only been able to record
the result of two neutron stars
collision in theory this process should
result in the formation of a neutron
star with an even bigger mass or else it
should cause the formation of a black
hole
when merging neutron stars are capable
of generating a magnetic field billions
of times more powerful than that of the
earth
this process may be accompanied by a
gamma ray flare
that is the most powerful energy
emission in the universe known to us i
mentioned it at some point in other
videos
however in spite of the tremendous scale
of this phenomenon astronomers have
never been able to directly observe the
process of merging stars
one of these events the grb-150
gamma-ray flare was detected only in
the event made it possible to draw
connection with gravity waves detected
back in 2015
gravity waves are also a result of two
neutron stars merging
it looks like something similar awaits
my cam as well and if a planetary system
were in its vicinity it would be a far
less serene place to be around in
comparison with our planet
the enormous mass of my cam is
indicative of its short life which leads
us to assume that intelligent organisms
would simply not have had enough time to
develop on its hypothetical planets
besides as the stellar system grows
older both its components increase in
their dimensions
this process brings
cam ever closer to its inevitable
destiny of becoming a supermassive
stellar giant and then an even heavier
neutron star or else a black hole
the my cam system is also peculiar for
the fact that it is located in a region
of the universe rather densely filled
with stars
regions like that are sometimes referred
to as globular star clusters
star mergers are rather common in areas
of this kind since the number of stars
there is by far greater than in our
system's proximity
according to the latest estimates star
collisions in globular star clusters
occur approximately once every 10 000
years
unlike m y cam objects like our sun are
sail drifters in a galaxy with only a
planetary system for company
however such celestial objects are not
that common in the universe
sun-like single stars in the milky way
account only for a measly two percent
most stars are part of multiple systems
for example triple star systems are the
most common accounting for about 75
percent of all observable stars
most of them have to struggle with the
gravity force of their companions
throughout their lifetime
this interaction in its turn leads to
the formation of even larger stellar
systems
most of the supermassive stars known
today may at one point have been part of
systems with at least one companion of
an identical mass
thanks to frequent eclipses occurring in
multiple star systems scientists are
able to investigate the celestial
objects in more detail in the case of my
cam for instance
astrophysicists detected a wide range of
specters of light emanating from it
they went on to use the doppler effect
thus measuring the star's orbital speeds
with this knowledge it was safe to
maintain that my cam is an exceptional
object in space
in the future this stellar system will
enable us to confirm some hypotheses as
to the formation of massive stars in our
galaxy
when celestial objects like that are
discovered we grow ever stronger in our
belief that our universe is an amazing
place concealing an unimaginably large
number of as yet unknown phenomena
each of them poses a hurdle for science
but once it is negotiated our
civilization continues to develop and
expand its knowledge about space
surrounding us
we will soon get even more information
about my camelot pardolis as an object
with such exciting properties can't but
attract attention of scientists all over
the world there is no knowing what
features of star formation we will be
aware of at that time but it is safe
enough to say even now that these remote
gigantic stars will never cease to amaze
us
the term stellar evolution in astronomy
refers to the sequence of changes that a
star undergoes throughout its entire
life
this process largely depends on the
object's initial mass and may take
anything from several million to tens of
billions of years
as a rule a star originates from a cloud
of code low pressure interstellar gas
due to gravitational instability the
cloud compresses and eventually slowly
assumes a spherical shape
during the compression process the
gravitational field energy is
transformed into heat and radiation with
the temperature of the young star
gradually going up
the duration of this stage depends
directly on the star's initial mass
with the heaviest stars it may take
about a hundred thousand years and with
the lightest ones the phase may last up
to several billion years our sun's mass
for instance is comparatively small and
so it remained in this first phase for
approximately 110 million years in the
next phase after a sufficiently high
temperature has been reached to the core
thermonuclear fusion takes place inside
the star and the compression ceases
after this the processes taking place at
the core become the star's only energy
source and thus a young star which is
also called a protester becomes a main
sequence star
this is the starting point for
calculating a star's age as this phase
accounts for approximately 90 percent of
its life cycle
our sun for example will remain in the
main sequence stage for approximately
eleven and a half billion years
when a star enters its main sequence
stage its chemical composition is still
very close to interstellar environment
and is 91
hydrogen at the same time the process of
hydrogen transforming into helium is
constantly in progress inside the star
as a result the core compresses and
gains and density which gradually
increases the rate of chemical reactions
it leads to noticeable changes in the
star's properties for example the
luminosity of our sun in the main
sequence stage accounted for only 70
percent of its luminosity today
by the time the stage is over the
luminosity is going to be 2.2 times that
of today
it should be mentioned that not all
stars make it to the main sequence stage
the exceptions known to science today
are referred to as code and hot
subdwarves
these objects are very similar to main
sequence stars but they do differ from
them thus by contrast sub dwarves are
not rich in heavy elements and are not
so luminous
the final phase for main sequence stars
also depends on their mass
generally a star either discards its
outer coat thus becoming a white dwarf
or goes supernova to later become a
neutron star or a black hole
a supernova is a phenomenon when a
star's luminosity dramatically
intensifies with great amounts of energy
released during the process
after that the flare slowly fades this
explosion is accompanied by emissions of
great amounts of matter from the outer
coat the remaining mata in the core of
the star god supernova generally forms a
compact object either a neutron star or
a black hole
apart from everything else
the matter released in the course of a
supernova event contains products of
thermonuclear synthesis
it is thanks to these elements that the
universe is able to evolutionize
chemistry wise
if a star's mass doesn't quite reach
eight sun masses however this main
sequence star will end up being a white
dwarf
that is an object which is a hot
celestial body of small dimensions and a
high density
for instance in the case with our sun
when the time comes for it to go through
this phase it is going to become a
hundred times smaller than it is now
white dwarfs do not generate energy and
are luminous only on account of their
high temperature
even though the hottest white dwarf
surfaces may be as scorching as 70 000
kelvins due to their small size their
luminosity is not that great
as for their average density it is
almost a million times that of the
regular density of main sequence stars
these objects consist for the most part
of a plasma of nuclei and electrons and
are completely devoid of thermonuclear
energy sources
which is why they gradually cool off and
assume a red hue
sirius b is the closest white dwarf to
us that we currently know of and it is
8.6 light years away
this object's mass is give or take that
of the sun and is considered to be one
of the most massive white dwarfs known
today
its volume is a millionth of that of the
sun and its dimensions are identical to
those of our earth
sirius b is believed to have become a
white dwarf approximately 120 million
years ago with the initial mass of the
star in its main sequence phase having
been five sun masses
today it is posited that these objects
account for three to ten percent of the
overall stellar population of our galaxy
according to different estimates
over 97 percent of the stars known today
are eventually destined to become white
dwarfs
as time goes by these objects are bound
to cool off and fade
eventually all celestial bodies of this
variety will become black dwarves which
implies that they will completely cease
to emit any visible light
this process takes scores of billions of
years that is why to date science hasn't
had a chance to observe any of these
objects
the universe is considered to be too
young to have produced any black dwarves
at this point but scientists have
already managed to spot objects quite
similar to them whose temperature has
gone down lower than 4000 kelvins
these objects are white dwarfs
wd0346 plus 246
and sdss j110 200
a black dwarf is what most stars look
like at the final stage of their
revolution its mass is quite identical
to that of a white dwarf
according to today's models
demonstrating cooling of these bodies
white dwarfs formed in the course of the
evolution of the first generation of
stars are supposed to have a temperature
of approximately 3
200 kelvins and to appear as rather dim
objects for all we know these celestial
bodies could be part of the universe's
hidden mass components
for a white dwarf to cool off to the
temperature as low as 5 kelvins it may
take approximately 1 quadrillion years
in theory when black dwarves cool off
completely the process of dark matter
annihilation becomes very important for
their existence
this phenomenon hasn't been directly
observed in the universe yet although it
is thought that in the course of
annihilation particles of dark matter
will form ordinary photons and emit
light visible through a telescope
without allowing for this phenomenon
black dwarves are believed to cool off
and fade to the point where their
temperature equals the background
temperature of the universe
however in theory thanks to the energy
derived from dark matter annihilation
black dwarves may well continue to
radiate energy for a considerably longer
period and thus in
it is likely that mankind will never be
able to discover objects of this kind as
the main period of their life takes
place in the face and the life of our
universe which will come after the one
we're in at the moment
the period we live in is a starry park
that is the period where stars are still
born quite actively
this epoch will last up until the point
when the galaxies will deplete all of
their interstellar gas
after that it will be the turn of low
mass stars like our sun to fade
following that a long period of
disintegration will begin when white
brown and black dwarves are the main
objects populating the universe
at the next stage the epoch of black
holes all matter in the universe will be
transformed into elementary or subatomic
particles with the remaining black
dwarves getting sucked in by black holes
or completely disintegrating
the final stage in the life of the
universe is supposed to be the epoch of
eternal darkness where there won't be
any energy sources whatsoever in space
the overall temperature in the universe
will reach absolute zero
space will gradually expand and in the
light of the last and rare black holes
in about one google years our world will
come to its gloomy end
on our journey we have seen only a
handful of space objects but life is too
short to visit them all
and the life of the universe at that
but this doesn't interfere with our
motivation to carry on studying things
in space
which means that there is still a great
load of discoveries waiting to be made
[Music]
you